bonjour à toutes et à tous c'est paléo
news l'émission qui fait des news avec
du vieux alors il devient de plus en
plus de notoriété publique que je suis
chercheur en paléontologie ce qui est
vrai du coup il ya de plus en plus de
monde qui me demande qu'est ce que tu
fais comme recherche
alors il ya ceux qui le demande
gentiment et il ya ceux qui le demandent
en dix ans mais alors qu'est-ce que tu
connais toi pour te croire plus
intelligent que assez réussie
pseudo-scientifiques de votre choix
alors du coup aujourd'hui on va parler
de mes recherches puisque deux des
articles qu'on va aborder aujourd'hui
sont directement issus du travail que je
fais on commence par cet article sur la
paléo neurologie dans thésaurus
magnifique us donc la paléo neurologie
c'est-à-dire l'étude du système nerveux
des espèces éteintes de hanter aux
russes magnifique us qui est un
magnifique dinos et fall alors
magnifique d'unicef alors je vais vous
montrer cette très très belle
reconstitution fait par simple ex palais
au salut ciblex voilà allez voir sa
chaîne c'est que du bon donc si plex pas
d eau qui nous a fait cette magnifique
reconstitution de vente et aux orris
magnifique us vous voyez en théorie en
teoz horus magnifique us c'est à dino
ces failles c'est à dire que c'est un
reptile malien qui datent du permien
moyens et il est comme vous le voyez
carnivores en train de s'attaquer à ceux
moscovie natus qui lui était un autre
dit non ses fans mais herbivores dont
c'est un des éléments de la faune sud
africaines les plus abondants du permien
moyens et dans cet article paru dans
apte à palaeontologica polonica donc un
journal polonais qui est open access
donc l'article est disponible
gratuitement en ligne
je vous mettrai le lien dans la
description est bien dans cet article
nous avons nous nous sommes penchés sur
le système nerveux dans tes aux eaux
russes donc on a scanné un crâne dans
thésaurus ça a été une manoeuvre un peu
compliqué parce que le crâne était en
plein de petits morceaux
ce qui était intéressant pour nous parce
que du coup on n'a plus qu'un et chaque
morceau individuellement et avoir une
très très bonne résolution est un très
très bon contraste grâce aux rayons x
sur chaque morceau mais du coup après il
a fallu coller les morceaux en même
temps pour reconstituer un crâne entier
donc voilà le crâne entier et donc on
s'est penché sur l'oreille interne et le
cerveau dans tes aux eaux russes est en
fait ce qu'on a découvert c'est que
l'oreille interne et le cerveau d'un thé
aux russes ont des adaptations pour une
chasse
une chasse de proies rapide on va dire
donc commencer ça et bien l'oreille
interne dans tes aux eaux russes ses
skis en violet ici elle comporte des
canots semi circulaire comme tous les
vertébrés
comme tous les vertébrés ont des canots
semi circulaire un pour chaque dimension
de chacune des trois dimensions de
l'espace et ses canots semi circulaire
géante au zoo en teoz auris ils sont
relativement grand beaucoup plus grands
que sont que son relatif moscovie natus
ici est beaucoup plus grands aussi que
ceux des autres carnivores de la même
époque et plus ou moins de la même
taille comme les ikos eu l'idée par
exemple qu'ils étaient des terreaux
céphale aussi de grands carnivores du
permien moyens donc ces canots semi
circulaires sont plus grands que tout ce
qui existait à l'époque dans tes aux
eaux russes voilà et le cerveau lui
contient comportent par dont 7,7 chose
ce bulbe ici et ce bulbe très développés
c'est le lob
l'oculaire du cervelet et le locle
oculaire du cervelet comme l'oreille
interne sont directement
on joue tous les deux un rôle
directement dans la locomotion est aussi
dans la traque des proies donc il
coordonne les mouvements des yeux de la
tête et du corps dans la traque de la
broye ça on le sait pas ce qu'on a pu
étudier les animaux moderne pour le
déterminer et ses adaptations l'a donc
un très très gros l'ops l'oculaire et
une traite et de très très grands canaux
semi circulaires et bien ce sont des
adaptations qu'on retrouve chez des
prédateurs rapide notamment chez les
guépards et surtout chez les
velociraptor l'oreille interne et les
locle oculaire de dante et aux or quand
je les ai vus la première fois quand je
les ai reconstitué pour la première fois
en 3d le premier truc qui m'a frappé
c'est à quel point ils ressemblaient à
vail aussi raptor et ça ça veut dire que
rentrent et aux russes était un chasseur
relativement agile contrairement à ce
qu'on pourrait croire quand on sait
qu'il pesait quelques tonnes enfin au
moins une tonne
donc ça fait une bonne tonne de monstres
1 quand même donc je vous remets l'image
de simplex paléo voilà faut vous
imaginer que cette bête là là ça devait
faire retour d'une tonne à l'âge adulte
et bien cet animal là il était en fait
rapide alors c'est pas si étonnant que
ça parce qu'on a quand même des
animaux qui dépassent la tonne
aujourd'hui qui sont rapides comme les
rhinocéros par exemple les rhinocéros
sont capables de courir vite de galoper
donc ce n'est pas si étonnant que ça et
on pense du coup que lente et aux orres
devait être un animal relativement
rapide le problème c'est qu'on a
toujours pas de squelettes pour hanter
aux arts c'est d'ailleurs pour ça qu'on
s'est mis à étudier l'oreille interne et
le cerveau c'est parce qu'on n'a pas
vraiment de squelettes dans téoz or on a
un beau squelette de titane ou fonus qui
était un proche cousin dans théosophes
mais on a pas de bosse que l'aide dans
téoz or donc on sait pas trop comment
ils se déplaçaient lente et aux ors et
maintenant qu'on a cette oreille interne
eh bien on est capable de faire des
hypothèses sur la façon dont ante et aux
russes se déplaçait et tout du dans le
système nerveux ventes et aux eaux
russes indique qu'il se déplaçait
rapidement
la deuxième étude dont je voulais vous
parler c'est une étude qui est pas
qu'ils aient paru dans paléo géographie
paléoclimatologie est pas d eau écologie
à laquelle j'ai participé je ne suis pas
le premier auteur vous pouvez voir ici
j'ai participé j'ai notamment fait les
reconstitutions 3d de pour cette étude
et c'est une étude qui qui s'intéressent
addict dont dicte aux dons c'est un
petit encore une fois c'est un reptile
malien mais cette fois un herbivore
ça fait partie des dix hinault d'onde
c'est à dire les reptiles mama lien avec
un bec et des petites défense sur le
côté donc il avait à la fois un bec et
d'aider dans des grandes canines donc
elle est directement sont parmi les plus
abondants de c2c les petits maliens et
là ce qu'on a découvert enfin ce que ce
que nos collègues et moi même avons
découvert et bien c'est qu'en fait
dicton on le savait déjà
faisait des des terriers donc là ce que
vous avez c'est un terrier de dictons
avec la chambre terminal ici où se
trouve le squelette du dicton donc ça
déjà c'est vraiment pas mal comme comme
fossiles doit dire vous avez tous le
terrier plus le dicte aux dons à la fin
dans la chambre interminables et en fait
ce qu'on montre dans cet article c'est
que dans cette chambre terminal n'y a
pas que indique-t-on adultes donc ça
c'est le crâne d'un dicton vous voyez le
bec
vous voyez la défense ici vous voyez
l'oeil ici la fosse temporal l'arrière
du crâne
ici il n'ya pas seulement un adulte le
squelette d'un adulte donc là c'est
encore ça c'est le squelette c'est le
spécimen que je vais vous
juste après donc vous n'avez pas
seulement un adulte mais vous avez aussi
un juvénile
donc vous voyez là vous avez un scan qui
a été fait de ce spécimen là est sûre ce
scan vous avez l'adulte ici et vous avez
le juvénile juste là ici gros si vous
voyez la différence de taille on la voit
mieux sur la vidéo dont je vais vous
montrer la vidéo maintenant voilà la
vidéo une vidéo en 3d que j'ai fait à
partir du scan donc ce qu'on a fait
c'est qu'on a ramené ce gros spécimens
là ce gros bloc supposément issu d'un
terrier de dicton on l'a ramené au
synchrotron de grenoble où on l'as canet
avec mon collègue vincent fernandez
enfin en tout cas vincent fernandez l'as
cannes et moi je n'étais pas là je crois
pas que j'étais là ce jour là mais bref
il
vincent fernandez l'as canet et puis moi
j'ai fait en fait ces reconstitutions 3d
c'est à dire qu'une fois que le spécimen
est calée scanner il faut extraire tous
les os du bloc et donc moi j'ai extrait
tous ces ossements du blog donc vous
avez un gros crâne d'adultes dicte dont
vous avez ici le bébé dicte aux dents
qui va réapparaître juste en bas ici
voilà donc mais bdic taux de conserver
avec une bonne partie de son squelette
comme vous pouvez le voir vous avez un
autre animal qui s'appelle qui est un
terreau sefa liens et si vous avez
d'autres débris parmi lesquels les
débris d'un deuxième bébé dicton ça
c'est quand même très très intéressant
hélas en rouge vous avait possiblement
un troisième bébé dicte aux dons les
débris d'un troisième bébé dicton
donc on a au moins deux bébés dicte aux
dons peut-être un troisième dans se
préserver dans ce supposé terrier avec
un adulte dicte aux dons donc ça ça
démontre que alors l'édito dont on
savait déjà qu'ils creusent des terriers
parce qu'on l'a découvert depuis 1987 on
sait qu'ils édictent ont creusé des
terriers et ça a même été représenté
dans le reportage de la bbc donc je vous
affichez maintenant ce reportage de la
bbc le moment où il parle des dictons et
dans ce reportage de la bbc donc on voit
les dicte aux dons creuser des terriers
on voit les dicte aux dons vivre en
groupe alors ils appellent ça une
colonie je crois dans le reportage de la
bbc
donc dans ce reportage on y voit les
digues
on dans ce documentaire on voit lady
claude ont creusé des terriers et vivre
en groupe
donc c'est terrier en fait ils sont tous
au même endroit et on al impression qu
edith honan ils font des colonies un peu
comme l'est un peu comme les râteaux
tenu donc c'est pas tellement vrai ça en
fait ce qu'on démontre dans cet article
c'est plus qu'en fait ce groupement de
terrier qui existe vraiment on a
vraiment un endroit en afrique du sud où
on trouve plein de terriers de 10pts aux
dons c'est plus un artefact de
préservation c'est à dire qu on est
autour d'une rivière en fait d'une
rivière avec des méandres voilà c'est ce
qui l'expliqué ici donc on est autour
d'une rivière avec des méandres et en
fait les bords de cette rivière ici est
une très très forte sédimentation et en
même temps ses bords de rivières sont
très très mou donc c'est très facile d'y
creuser des terriers donc c'est pour ça
que les dictons
venez y creuser et que en plus comme on
a une forte sédimentation ya une forte
chance de préserver des terriers sous
forme de deux moulages de remplissage
sédimentaires comme si vous préférez
donc c'est juste un artefact en fait de
préservation c'est ils vivent pas
réellement colonies ces dictons
néanmoins c'est quand même intéressant
de trouver ce spécimen là en particulier
parce que cette fois pour la première
fois on a un juvénile dans le terrier
en réalité on en a deux on a ce spécimen
là et on a sept autres spécimens si
voilà avec un adulte et vous voyez ici
ce tout petit c'est tout petit petit
petit os avec l'adulte la pouf
le voilà c'est un numerus de juvéniles
c'est pas une phalange est on est on en
est sûr c'est complètement l'humérus
d'un juvénile donc on a maintenant deux
terriers dans lesquels on a trouvé des
juvéniles et des adultes de dictons et
ça ça veut dire que les dictons dont se
servait de leur terrier pour élever
leurs petits
en plus il ya des choses intéressantes
sur ces bébés dit où l'on voyait donc
ils n'ont pas de canines ils ont le
crâne plutôt plutôt rond alors que chez
l'adulte le crâne est relativement
allongée et surtout ils ont vous voyez
le sommet du crâne et très étendues
alors que chez les adultes il ya une
crête sagittale donc ça aussi c'est très
particulier chez ces bébés dicte aux
dons alors je peux vous montrer une
vidéo où on voit la différence de taille
entre les adultes
les juvéniles c'est assez c'est assez
beau à regarder
voilà donc là vous voyez le crâne de
l'adulte et là vous voyez le spécimens
juvéniles en entier voyait là ce bébé
dicté ou non là il est quasiment tout
entier vous avez la plupart du squelette
et vous voyez le crâne de l'adulte juste
à côté on pense même que sept adultes
finalement il est adulte mais pas pas
complètement mature parce que il n'a pas
encore de défense on voit que les
défenses en train de percer mais en fait
sept adultes devaient être en âge de se
reproduire mais pas encore pas encore
tout à fait adultes et alors le fait
qu'il allait défense en train de percer
indique que c'était un mal parce que
chez dicte aux dons on a les mâles qui
ont des défenses et les femelles qui
n'en ont pas donc le fait qu'il allait
défense en train de percer ça veut dire
que c'était le mal qui a été retrouvé
dans le terrier et c'est pareil pour le
2ème terrier le deuxième terrier c'est
aussi un mal qui a été retrouvé dans le
terrier comme vous allez voir sur cette
photo voyez donc cette photo on voit
bien la défense ici donc apparemment ce
sont les mâles dicte aux dents qui
prenez soin des petits donc ici vous
voyez la photo du mal avec ses dents en
train de sortir et la photo qui vient de
ce spécimen là et ici vous avez la photo
de l'autre terrier avec ce spécimen ci
où on voit bien les défenses qui sont
sortis donc apparemment c'était les
mâles qui s'occupait de l'élevage des
petits chez les dicte aux dents avec les
femelles qui allaient chercher la
nourriture probablement donc un peu ce
qu'on retrouve aujourd'hui chez les
oiseaux il ya beaucoup de l'oiseau chez
qui on retrouve ce genre de comportement
là donc voilà pour tous ceux qui se
demandaient ce que je fais comme
rechercher ben voila je fais des
recherches sur les reptiles mamma mia et
notamment j'utilise des sites is khan
pour voir les choses qu'on n'était pas
capable de voir avant parce que si on
n'avait pas de calais tous a lancé aux
orres ou bien le terrier de victo d'en
bas on n'aurait pas vu tout ce qu'on ya
trouvé notamment on n'aurait pas vu le
deuxième le deuxième et le troisième
bébé dicte aux dons on en aurait vu
qu'un seul parce que le deuxième et le
troisième ils sont complètement à
l'intérieur du caillou donc à aucune
chance qu'on les ait trouvé donc voilà
c'est à ça que c'est à ça que je sers
voilà je
fait des scans à rayons x de fossiles
pour voir les choses qu'on n'arrivait
pas à voir avant alors on reste en
afrique du sud avec cette fois une autre
équipe complètement je ne suis plus à
partir de mai à partir de maintenant les
articles qu'on va voir je n'en ai pas
fait partie même ceux qui viennent
d'afrique du sud donc là on reste en
afrique du sud avec une étude une étude
daf aussi la fin d'une série de faux
cils très intéressante puisque ce sont
des fossiles de lamproies qui viennent
du carbonifère du début du carbonifère
d'afrique du sud et ses faux cils de
l'emploi en fait c'est une série
oncogénique ça veut dire qu'on a tous
depuis les bébés jusqu'aux adultes et
notamment au niveau des bébés on a tous
depuis des bébés là vous voyez c'est une
larve de lamproies est ici vous avez le
sac vite hélas donc vous avez vraiment
toute la série depuis l'éclosion jusque
jusqu'à la lamproie adultes que vous
voyez ici qu'on reconnaît très bien
puisqu'elle a sa ventouse au bout de la
bouche
donc ce que c'était une nous montre
c'est très intéressant ça a été publiée
dans nature veut c'est vous dire si
c'est intéressant c'est qu'en fait les
lamproies du carbonifère avaient un
développement avaient un développement
qui est très classique on va dire dans
le sens où bat l'ebbe donc ce que vous
voyez là il avait déjà une ventouse et
il avait déjà des gros yeux
donc c'était plus ou moins des modèles
miniatures de l'adulte en fait alors que
les lamproies moderne
elles n'ont pas un développement comme
ça les lamproies moderne quand elles
naissent elle ressemble basiquement à
des verts elles n'ont pas de ventouses
elles ont des tout petits petits yeux à
peine à peine visible à l'oeil nu
donc en fait on pensait que le
développement des lamproies parce que
vous connaissez certainement ce vieil
adage qui est que l'on au génie avec
capitule la phylogénie à savoir que les
bébés des espèces modernes seraient des
des images serait représentatif de la
morphologie de ce qui était leur ancêtre
en fait donc en gros si on suit cette
logique un bébé humain devrait
ressembler à un chimpanzé
voilà donc ça c'est pour vous souligner
le fait que globalement l'auto genia
récapitule la phylogénie ça marche que
quand que dans quelques cas très très
spécifiques
ça marche pas en général en fait ça
arch quand on regarde les caractères et
donc on se servait de la lamproie on se
servait de ce vieil adage sur les
enfants en disant bas les lamproies se
transforme au cours de leur honte au
génie donc les bébés qui ressemble à des
verts se transforme ensuite en poissons
donc ça veut dire que lancent les
ancêtres des vertébrés puisque en plus
on s'imagine que la lamproie est un
fossile vivant évidemment sinon ce n'est
pas drôle donc ans email et cette larve
d'ailleurs s'appelle la moss est c'est
pour ça que vous voyez ce mot ici la
beauce est donc cette larve amos est qui
ressemble à un verre et bien elle serait
représentatif de ce qui était l'ancêtre
des vertébrés la lamproie 1 est en
elle-même un fossile vivant donc tout ce
qui concerne la lamproie est forcément
ancestrales et forcément primitif eh
bien non cet article vous démontre que
le développement de la lamproie en fait
des lamproies moderne il a rien à voir
avec le développement des lamproies du
carbonifère et ça ça veut dire que les
lamproies ne sont absolument pas des
fossiles vivants leurs larves amos est
est en fait extrêmement dérivés en fait
elle n'a rien à voir avec ce qui était
les larmes de leurs ancêtres du
carbonifère la larve amos est c'est
quelque chose d'extrêmement récent
évolutive mans parlant ce n'est pas un
caractère ancestral
donc non dans le cadre dans le cas des
lamproies long au génie ne récapitule
pas la phylogénie et en plus les
l'emploi ne sont pas des fossiles
vivants puisque leurs larves ont évolué
leur morphologie larvaires du mois a
évolué elle n'est plus la même que celle
qu'elle était au carbonifère donc cet
article il casse quand même deux grosses
d'idées reçues
il mérite bien sa place dans et cher on
reste chez les poissons avec une étude
française
en tout cas en partie française dirigée
par romain vue law de l'université de
rennes et ses collègues alors il a des
collègues allemands et là des collègues
mexicains apparemment aussi qui décrit
un nouveau fossile de requins donc un
requin l'âme ni forme si je ne m'abuse
qui nous vient du crétacé donc ce requin
a la particularité déjà d'être
complètement préservé ce qui arrive
suffisamment rarement chez les requins
pour le préciser parce que chez les
requins comme le
comme le squelette et cartilagineuse ce
sont les fameux poisson cartilagineux et
bien comme ces requins sont
cartilagineux on trouve jamais de
squelettes donc déjà on a un squelette
complet ce qui est suffisamment
remarquable pour être noté et surtout
emma ce requin il assez grande ces
espèces de grandes ailes voilà ces
grandes nageoires sur le côté qui sont
très très visible sur le fossile et ses
grandes nageoires sur le côté passé
quelque chose de tout à fait unique on
n'a jamais vu ça avant chez un requin on
a vu ça éventuellement chez drm et c'est
pas exactement la même morphologie et de
toute façon ce n'est pas une ré sets à
rien et en plus la morphologie de sa
mâchoire indique qu'il était filtreurs
c'était pas un requin un prédateur
c'était un requin filtreurs un peu comme
les requins baleines
donc c'est une morphologie tout à fait
atypique pour ce requin qui lui a valu
d'être parue dans la revue science
donc le grand concurrent de nature qu'on
a vu juste avant et ça indique une
certaine diversité déjà des requins du
crétacé donc encore une fois requins
grand exemple de fossiles vivants de
trucs qui n'auraient pas évolué et bien
non un des requins ont bel et bien
évolué il avait déjà une grande histoire
évolutive
il y à il y as an une centaine de
millions d'années et ils ont toujours
une grande histoire évolutive évidemment
une grande diversité morphologique et
génétique sans transition maintenant
nous allons parler d'évolution humaine
avec un article que vous avez dû voir
passer puisque l'évolution humaine
généralement ça fait beaucoup de bruit
c'est un article qui déclarait en fin du
mois c'est un article qui a été vendu
sur le fait qu'il déclarait que
néandertal était capable de parler donc
ça y est la fameuse capacité de parler
chez néandertal aurait finalement été
démontrée et ben non toujours pas donc
c'est une équipe principalement
espagnols qui a publié sa dans une dans
une sous revue de nature's qui s'appelle
leicher écologie et évolution
donc ils ont étudié l'oreille interne et
l'oreille moyenne des crânes de
néandertal et 2
de près néandertaliens d'espagne et
d'europe en général donc les prêts
envers tous les prêts néandertaliens de
la cimade et le souhait sauce
généralement attribuée à augmenter ses
sorts et donc en étudiant l'oreille
interne et l'oreille moyenne de ses
nerfs bertal ils ont réussi en fait à
faire des corrélations avec les
capacités auditives des espèces modernes
afin de reconstituer ce spectre qui est
le spectre auditifs on va dire de de
néandertal comparé à celui d' homo
sapiens en bleu donc vous avez
néandertal en bleu foncé vous avez homo
sapiens en bleu et vous avez les prêts
néandertaliens en rouge et dans ce qu'il
faut voir ici c'est que les spectres
auditifs sont très similaires
les spectres d'audition sont très
similaires à part sur cette extrémité là
ou là vous avez une nette différence
entre les prêts en herbe n'est prêt
néandertaliens d'un côté et les
néandertaliens et homo sapiens de
l'autre donc ce qui veut dire enfin ce
qui veut dire selon ses auteurs que
néandertal était capable d'entendre
exactement les mêmes choses que homo
sapiens y compris évidemment la parole
donc néandertal était capable d'entendre
exactement les mêmes choses qu'homo
sapiens est apparemment dans cette
région là du spectre auditifs ce qui s'y
passe c'est surtout des consonnes lé
concerne c'est quand même super
important pour articuler pour se faire
comprendre
donc on aurait néandertal qui
entendraient la même chose qu'aux mots
sa place donc ça ça démontre qu'ils
étaient capables d'entendre la même
chose mais ça démontre pas qu'ils
étaient capables de parler exactement
comme homo sapiens donc ça suggère très
fortement qu'ils étaient capables du
coup de parler puisque ça puisque ça
montre qu'ils entendaient la même chose
dont il était capable probablement de
parler de la même façon mais mais en
aucun cas on ne démontre qu'ils étaient
capables de parler après ça va quand
même dans le sens de plusieurs études
qui ont notamment l'appareil hyoïde donc
au niveau de la gorge la glotte
il ya eu une époque une étude qui avait
dit que les néandertal était incapable
de parler parce que la glotte elle
n'était pas positionné au bon endroit
bombe à tout ça ça a été complètement
des bunkers récemment donc la glotte
elle a tout ce qu'il faut
il faut pour que néandertal puisse
parler les on a aussi bien que
néandertal un comportement qui est tout
à fait similaire - sapiens je veux dire
toucher néandertal est extrêmement
similaires sapiens 1 on pensait qu'il
n'était pas capable de faire des
peintures rupestres finalement si on
pensait qu'il faisait pas de parures
finalement si on pensait qu'ils voient
là on pensait que c'était un crétin qui
vivaient dans des grottes et finalement
non il faisait plein de trucs
exactement comme homo sapiens donc
néandertal qui parle j'ai envie de dire
c'est pas non plus une si grosse
hypothèse que ça ça va donc oui je pense
dans mon intime conviction que
néandertal était capable de parler
exactement comme au sein pias cet
article là tout seul des montres
uniquement que homo sapiens et homo
neanderthalensis avait les mêmes
capacités auditives ce qui est déjà
remarquable je veux dire on est capable
de reconstituer les capacités auditives
d'un truc qui a complètement disparu
j'ai envie de dire quand même faut quand
même rendre à césar ce qui est à césar
c'est une étude qui est remarquable
quand même on reste dans l'évolution
humaine mais cette fois avec un petit
déblocage parce qu'évidemment la
dernière fois j'ai vu que ça vous avait
plus eu le temps que j'avais passé à
souffrir en vous des bonnes quand le
spinosaures donc on va se refaire un
petit des mêmes cages mais cette fois un
peu plus rapide quand même d'un article
qui est sorti tout récemment dans une
revue qui s'appelle et ready tasse donc
qui appartient au groupe bmc donc j'ai
une petite revue mais qui est quand même
qui est quand même notable revue qui est
qui est connu et donc dans cette revue
vous avez deux chercheurs suédois si je
ne m'abuse
en tout cas scandinaves qui ont fait une
analyse génétique de au mossad
enfin de tous les représentants du genre
homo dont on a du matériel génétique
donc c'est à dire homo sapiens homo
neandertalensis et denisot va et depuis
tout récemment on a vanté ses sorts
aussi donc ils font une analyse
génétique et ils font un arbre
phylogénétique que vous voyez là et ils
disent que homo sapiens nous vient
d'asie eh oui homo sapiens ne viendrait
pas d'afrique selon eux il viendrait
d'asie et il apporterait enfin la preuve
que l'homo sapiens viendrait en fait
d'asie et bien cet article je n'aime pas
du tout non
pas parce que je suis un chien de garde
de la l'origine africaine et de l'offre
au centrisme mais parce que cet article
il a des gros problèmes méthodologiques
et puis c'est toujours pareil de toute
façon avec les gens qui disent comment
sapiens je viens pas d'afrique
c'est que en fait si vous voulez il y a
des défauts évidents dans la recherche
qui dit que homo sapiens vient d'afrique
il y a des défauts et ils sont visibles
je veux dire y'a pas de soucis à propos
de ça je le suis pas je suis pas le
dernier d'ailleurs à critiquer les
recherches là dessus quand elles sont
mauvaises mais par contre les recherches
qui disent que homo sapiens via d'asie
elles sont pires
elles sont mille fois pire
et là on en a un exemple qui est assez
flagrant alors je remercie d'ailleurs
celui qui me l'a envoyé ajax si tu nous
écoutes et je sais que tu nous écoutes
puisque tu me l'a envoyé en me disant
tiens tu pourrais pas en parler donc
voilà ajax je te remercie de m'avoir
d'avoir porté cet article à ma
connaissance
parce que là pour le coup on a un
exemple assez classique de gros gros
gros billets de confirmation quoi c'est
à dire que l'on part du principe de
toute façon il n'ya même pas de biais de
confirmation à à mettre en avant c'est
juste la méthode regarder la méthode
c'est on va construire un arbre
phylogénétique de tous les espèces du
genre en nous pour lesquelles on a de
l'adn donc vous avez néandertal qui est
ici représentée par hsn m vous avez en
tc sort h à vous avez denisova h snd et
vous avez homo sapiens hs
donc voilà c'est ça que ces acronymes
veulent dire on fait un arbre
phylogénétique ce que vous voyez devant
vous et puis sur cet arbre
phylogénétique on y met la géographie
donc en rouge
l'afrique en bleu eurasiatique et
évidemment pas la racine d'homo sapiens
apparaît en bleu et c'est ensuite
seulement que homo sapiens serait
retourné en afrique pour se re
diversifiée en afrique
alors quel est le problème avec ça bah
c'est tout simple homo sapiens vient
d'afrique et après vous avez quoi dans
votre analyse phylogénétique vous avez
encaissé sort qui vient de
qui vient d'europe vous avez néandertal
qui vient d'europe et d'asie et vous
avez denisot va qui vient d'asie et
c'est tout ce qu'il ya dans votre
analyse donc dans votre analyse en fait
il ya dans votre analyse phylogénétique
il n'y a que des espèces eurasiatique à
par homo sapiens à quel résultat vous
vous attendez voilà vous avez vous avez
deux minutes parce que c'est très facile
quand vous placez une espèce au milieu
une espèce avec une origine particulière
dont vous essayez de savoir l'origine
pardon au milieu d'autres espèces dont
l'origine est exactement la même belle
espèce dont on sait dont on cherche à
savoir l'origine va forcément avoir la
même origine que les autres puisqu'elle
est tout seul
voilà donc c'est comme si je disais ben
voilà les marsupiaux on va faire une
analyse phylogénétique des marsupiaux et
puis je vais la faire en ne plaçant que
des espèces africaines
et puis à la fin je vais découvrir que
les marsupiaux sont d'origine africaine
évidemment puisque j'ai placé avec les
marsupiaux je n'ai passé que des espèces
africaines
donc évidemment si je fais une analyse
phylogénétique des espèces africaines et
que je rajoute les marsupiaux à la fin
évidemment que je vais conclure bah oui
les marsupiaux zaugg origines africaines
évidemment alors que c'est assez évident
que non j'ai à dire donc là c'est
exactement le même problème vous n'avez
que des espèces asiatiques sauf sapiens
dont on cherche à déterminer l'origine
à votre avis par où qui va sortir ça
bien bas il va forcément sortir d'asie
évidemment donc
donc voilà c'est l' énorme biais
méthodologiques et qui à mon avis touche
à la malhonnêteté
parce qu'on pourrait dire bon bah voilà
ils ont voulu être honnête on pourrait
dire qu'ils ont voulu être honnête parce
que ben voilà évidemment ils ont pris
les séquences génétiques qu'on avait et
évidemment on n'a pas d'autres espèces
éteintes que néandertal denisot va et
entassés sort donc ils ont pris des
espèces qu'on avait bon ben pas de bol
elle sont tous eurasiatique bon réalité
c'est pas une question de chance et une
question de moyens c'est en europe qu'on
a les moyens de faire des analyses
génétiques sur le matériel qu'on a en
europe
donc voilà non s'il y avait plus de
d'études comme ça focaliser sur
l'afrique ça deviendrait intéressant
mais y'en a pas en tout cas pas pour
l'instant
donc voilà on en a ce biais on va dire
on a un billet d'échantillonnage majeur
pour les espèces qui ont vécu en eurasie
parce que c'est là qu'ils aient les
moyens c'est vrai que c'est là qu'il ya
le matos et c'est là qu'on a les
séquenceurs qu'il faut pour faire ça
donc on a un énorme biais
méthodologiques de ce point de vue là et
selon moi ça touche à la malhonnêteté
quand on voit en fait le reste de
l'article
déjà le reste de l'article va passer un
moment à essayer de critiquer du coup
l'origine africaine
l'hypothèse de l'origine africaine mais
alors il va le faire en citant des trucs
mais alors des journaux voilà c'est ce
que j'aime il a désigné des études qui
date des années 90 donc voilà l'origine
africaine c'est de la merde parce que
ben parce que dans les années 90 voilà
on a des gars qui ont fait des dégâts
qui ont fait des études mais ces études
elles sont complètement fausses alors
oui la génétique dans les années 90 et
la préhistoire c'est normal la regarde
et je vous montre ici tu les études 1 et
2 donc 1 et 2 vous avez nature's 1987
c'est même pas les années 90 je veux
dire c'est aussi vieux que moi et là
vous avez 1991 veux dire c'est vraiment
la naissance de la génétique donc
critiquer c'est à dire que critiquer les
résultats des analyses génétiques des
années 90 c'est je pense c'est un peu
comme prendre une pelle pour essayer d'
écraser une mouche
j'ai pas attaqué à quelqu'un de ta
taille le dire prends des études
récentes je veux dire depuis les années
90 on a des analyses du génome entier
qui soutiennent l'origine africaine de
l'humanité on a des jeux d'hier pour
encore une fois pour avoir une origine
non africaines de l'humanité il faut
arriver à expliquer pourquoi la totale
la quasi-totalité de la diversité
génétique humaine est centrée sur
l'afrique
c'est pourquoi le reste de la de la
diversité génétique humaine semble être
semble avoir divergé d'un tout petit
bout de cette diversité africaine qui
vient comme par hasard du nord-est de
l'afrique donc précis
mandla où tu t'attends à ce que les homo
sapiens et commencé à conquérir le reste
du monde
il faut arriver à se rendre compte de
tout ça à rendre compte de tout ça et ça
ça rend pas compte de tout ça sarr en
rien sa rencontre de rien du tout alors
eux ils essayent de il se noie dans une
explication où il essaie de faire en
sorte qu'il y ait plusieurs vagues de
migrations voyez donc pour eux il ya
plusieurs vagues de migration depuis
l'asie à l'afrique qui ont empilé de la
diversité génétique en afrique et
ensuite toute la diversité génétique
eurasiatique a disparu ce qui fait
qu'aujourd'hui on a plus que de la
diversité génétique en afrique c'est pas
impossible
c'est pas impossible mais alors c'est
capilotractée c'est horriblement
capilotractée est donc là où je voulais
dire que ça en touche à de la sa touche
à de la malhonnêteté intellectuelle
c'est sur cette figure là donc cette
figure là est censé nous dire regardez
on a tout le registre fossile humain en
asie qu'on ignore alors là il ya quand
même une un appel à la théorie du
complot qui est vous qui est bon
excellente et donc l'appel à la théorie
du complot qui dit vous voyez tous ces
fossiles asiatiques qui ont été ignorées
par les chercheurs occidentaux etc
regardez on a des homo sapiens jusqu'à
il ya trois cent mille ans en asie on a
des regardez comme c'est des homo
sapiens jusqu'à 300 milles en asie et on
a des homo sapiens archaïque jusqu'à 900
mille ans en asie alors qu'en afrique on
à homo sa place archaïque il a trois
cent mille ans est le premier homo
sapiens donc sapiens anatomiquement
modernes
il a deux cent mille ans donc là on and
on a quasiment l'homo sapiens a
recueilli jusqu'à un million d'années
est coincé c'est magnifique c'est
grandiose
d'ailleurs c'est exceptionnel ouais sauf
que cette figure aller repomper de d'un
autre article
donc autre article qui est citée ici
donc article 56 donc j'ai retrouvé cet
article pour vous voilà donc c'est un
article qui a été publié par ses
collègues
et là on va retrouver notre figure
le petit est là ah mais c'est plus la
même dit moi alors on a des homo sapiens
effectivement sur la figure au moderne
homo sable homo sapiens moderne dont le
plus ancien ici est à un peu plus de
cent mille ans ce qui est tout à fait
cohérent avec une sortie d'une sortie
d'afrique il y a entre 100 et 120
milliards entre 100 et 120 milles en
avance à la les trucs en bleu là dont il
disait que c'était des moderne homo
sapiens là sur sa figure là avant ça
vous avez alors archaïque homo sapiens
or denisovan ou des denisovians ah mais
ça change tout ça parce que des
denisovians on en a la preuve qu'ils
étaient là il ya au moins 40 milles ans
ne peut être lié à cent mille ans mais
alors par contre des homo sapiens on en
a toujours à rien là c'est
essentiellement du matériel lithique un
qu'on a c'est pas tellement du squelette
alors après vous pouvez chercher c'est
l'homme de dalila celui là qui est
considérée comme archaïque homo sapiens
peut aller chercher sur internet l'homme
de dali voilà si vous faites une
recherche google images avec dali skull
shayna parce que sinon vous allez tomber
sur le crâne de salvador dali donc dali
skull china ça c'est le crâne de l'homme
de dali le crâne de l'homme de dali ou
aces et des énormes bon les suces
orbitaire un crâne le sommet du crâne
bien fuyant une mâchoire gigantesque
bref c'est pas du tout à nos maux
sapiens moderne et vue étant donné qu'on
a ces deux gros pour les suces orbitaire
qui lui donne un air colère il allait il
n'a pas l'air content ça c'est
typiquement homo heidelbergensis la
leyre colère comme ça c'est de le
berghain 6 donc c'est la même espèce que
supposément la même espèce parce
qu'évidemment les attributions
taxonomique sur les fossiles sont
toujours des hypothèses mais c'est
supposément la même espèce que l'homme
de tautavel
donc voilà ça c'est pas du tout homo
sapiens moderne ou même relativement
archaïque que je vais vous montrer celui
de djebel est rude
donc le groupe spl ça c'est ça c'est
considéré comme homo sapiens alors
archaïque à tendance moderne pas
là ça le boulot issus orbitaire il est
beaucoup plus fin et vous voyez que le
crâne il est beaucoup plus haut par
contre on n'a toujours pas de menton
voyez ça c'est assez archaïque comme
très on n'a toujours pas de menton et on
a toujours un bonne grosse mâchoire avec
un petit rôle
donc ça c'est typiquement homo sapiens
archaïques comme moi sapiens il ya trois
cent mille ans et d'afrique
du coup afrique du nord pour celui là
donc ça c'est pour la partie bleue de la
figure et maintenant si on descend à la
partie verte ces homo erectus
alors que là la partie en bas du graff
la archaïque sapiens voilà donc lui
l'appel pour pour les vrais
paléontologues qui ont fait la figure
originale cette partie en verte ces homo
erectus alors que pour lui ça devient de
l'archaïque sapiens donc là on touche à
de la malhonnêteté intellectuelle la la
il ya falsification et à la
falsification des données non non cet
article il démontrera rien du tout il
démontre absolument rien la méthodologie
de l'analyse génétique et péter
l'analyse des du registre fossile et
péter le seul truc que je veux bien lui
accorder c'est qu'effectivement
maintenant qu'on a des données
d'augmenter ses sorts et que apparemment
l'analyse génétique d'augmenter ses
soeurs indique qu'il était plus que
c'est une branche divergentes qui serait
issu d'un ancêtre en commun entre d'un
côté néandertal sapiens et de l'autre
homo antecessor on a effectivement une
petite une petite suggestion
qu'effectivement le peut-être l'ancêtre
ans comme anne tout ce beau monde était
asiatique
mais encore une fois c'est aussi et
surtout parce qu'on n'a pas de données
génétiques des espèces africaines de la
même époque
parce que là la sq il faudrait jeter
dans le mix c'est dave haywood
typiquement aurait jeté jebali rood
faudrait jeter des ailes de bergen 6
comme le crâne de cabot est par exemple
qui vient du qu'il ya deux ans bis si je
ne m'abuse
je sais plus si c'est en biais ou
zimbabwe bref faudrait jeter des
d'heidelberg n 6 qui viennent d'afrique
dans ta pas seulement des ventes et ses
sorts des antécédents et des
néandertaliens des espèces africaines
danse graff
voilà c'est tout pour pouvoir réellement
testé l'hypothèse d'une origine
asiatique mais c'est vrai je leur
concède tout de même que remonter ses
sorts fout la merde faut attendre plus
de données en tout cas ce qui est
certain c'est que cet article là il est
donné on quitte les vertébrés pour finir
en beauté avec les invertébrés je parle
je parle jamais d'invertébrés donc voilà
on va parler un petit peu de trucs qui
n'ont pas de colonne vertébrale pour
terminer le meilleur pour la fin j'ai
envie de dire pour tous les invertébrés
east qui nous regardent ils sont pas
nombreux un verre terroriste si vous
êtes dans l'est si vous êtes là en train
de regarder lâché un commentaire que je
sache
- s'il y en a je parle tellement tout le
temps de vertébrés je veux dire que je
me demande même s'il ya des affaires
terroristes qui me regardent alors si
vous êtes là faisait du bruit dans les
commentaires voilà donc évidemment un
article qui m'a été demandé en fin et
qu'on m'a demandé une analyse de cet
article là mais je suis pas la verte et
brice alors je vais faire de mon mieux
mais c'est ce truc là qui a été retrouvé
donc en allemagne dans des gisements
alors je crois que c est à tous seuls
nos fans je ne suis pas sûr ouais c'est
acheter
helstad essonne offence est globalement
le même type de préservation c'est du
calcaire lithographique qui datent du
jurassique il ya 150 millions d'années
c'est là dedans qu'on a retrouvé
archéoptéryx c'est du dépôt lagunaire et
donc dans une de ces plaques
lithographiques ils ont retrouvé ça ils
ont retrouvé ce globe vaguement roulé de
ce côté là et de ce côté là ils ont
retrouvé ce qu'on appelle des aptitudes
les haptique us c'est le bec en gros dés
qu'on retrouve chez les céphalopodes ce
petit côté enroulé la plus le fait qu'on
retrouve avec de céphalopodes de ce
côté-là ça suggère que c'était que ceci
est un corps muda maudite qui s'est
retrouvée on sait pas trop comment
complètement séparée de sa coquille
alors la coquille s'était dissoute ou
alors l'hypothèse qu'ils font c'est que
c'est qu'il ya eu un prédateur qui
aurait extirper la bonite auraient
perforé la coquille
l'image qu'on voit plus loin voilà donc
il ya un prédateur qui auraient perforé
la coquille pour extirper la bonite de
ceux de sakho qui en fait est que du
coup ce truc là
ce blog qui restait bien ce serait
déposée aurait fossilisé alors bon c'est
capillotracté mais en même temps on
trouve on trouve tellement de fossiles
d'invertébrés que probable en terme pur
de en termes de probabilités pure ce
n'est pas improbable que ça se produise
au moins une fois
voilà un bon donc on va leur concéder sa
maintenant là où j'ai un problème c'est
surtout sur l'interprétation c'est à
dire que ok je veux bien ça je veux bien
croire que ça c'est peut-être du tissus
mous d'ammonites bon déjà les
identifications en tant qu à monique
dans la mesure où il ya un haptique us
attaché dessus c'est à peu près sûr que
c'est une ammonite voilà c'est passé un
peu près sûr que c'est un céphalopode et
apparemment ils ont identifié la petite
puce puisqu'il ya des moyens
d'identifier ses aptitudes
c'est définitivement de la petite puce
d'ammonites donc c'est du bec
d'ammonites donc ok c'est une ammonite
on le sait parce qu'on a la partie dure
ça s'est joué c'est plié
donc ok pour l'identification de la
maudite
là on voit qui a cinq qui a un petit
organe qui est sombre et eux il me
semble qu'il interprète comme étant
alors moi j'aurais dit une poche à encre
mais apparemment ils veulent pas une
poche et en qui il voit plutôt des yeux
voilà bon admettons donc là on voit
qu'il ya un truc là on voit une partie
du corps enroulé donc c'est possible
effectivement que ce soit une ammonite
on voit une partie du corps enroulé est
ici les identifier un tube digestif
alors tube digestif qui est recouvert de
chitine donc là qu'ils ont passé ça aux
uv et effectivement la chitine bris aux
uv donc je veux bien qu'on identifie ça
comme un tube digestif ça ça me va par
contre le reste je veux dire l'organe
reproducteur là ici le manteau ruf
enfin tout le reste collé ici voix des
restes des branches il a sur les côtés
là ces deux trucs là ce serait des
restes des branchies l'interprétation là
vous avez une glande salivaire de
glandes salivaires
m enfin le reste de l'interprétation je
veux dire je veux bien croire que ça
c'est un oeil
je veux bien croire que ça c'est un bout
d'intestin le reste le reste je suis pas
convaincu leurs essais un blob donc et
tout le reste de toute façon a été
identifiée juste parce qu'ils ont
comparé sa au nautile donc en réalité
c'est juste par comparaison en utile
qu'ils ont identifié tout le reste à
savoir quand on est peut-être sur une
pareille dolly niveau intersidéral quoi
si ça semble un pari d'owlient c'est
vouloir voir ce qu'on veut voir quand on
veut le voir
voilà donc là peut-être qu'ils ont un
peu voilà je veux bien croire que ça
c'est quelque chose s'ils disent hanoi
bon et sur la tête donc on peut
raisonnablement imaginer que c'est un
oeil
je veux bien croire que ça c'est du tube
digestif vu qu'ils ont passé les uv
qu'ils y ont vu de la chitine le reste
des organes je ne pense pas que je pense
pas qu'on puisse raisonnablement dire
qu'ils ont tort ou à raison c'est ça le
problème en fait si ça ça ressemble
s'assemble avoir une forme très
particulière à la limite ils disent que
ça ressemble vraiment une glande
digestive d'un dan utile pourquoi pas
mais le reste c'est interprété c'est
interprété à la truelle à mon avis mais
bon c'est intéressant quand même d'avoir
un je veux bien adhérer au fait que
c'est effectivement que cette crotte de
nez est effectivement une ammonite ou a
été une ammonite mais alors il reste
plus grand chose de la valide et
notamment il manque la partie qui aura
été la plus intéressante à savoir les
tentacules parce que c'est quand même ça
le problème que j'ai le plus avec cette
publication c'est qu'il manque quand
même les tentacules
donc même si je veux bien croire que cet
art est d'ammonites c'est quand même un
reste d'ammonites dont il reste plus
grand chose
c'est pour ça que selon moi cette
interprétation là où il voit tous ses
organes à l'intérieur elle est un peu
capilotracté c'est que j'ai à dire vous
avez une ammonite qui est à l'évidence
dans un état de décomposition extra
avancer donc vouloir y voir tout ce que
vous croyez y voir ça me semble un peu
beaucoup donc et non on n'a pas les
tentacules et quand même l'une des
grosses questions sur les ammonites sait
combien elles avaient tentacules est-ce
qu'elle en avait beaucoup comme les
notes il est ce qu'elle en avait que
huit comme les pierres ou est ce qu'elle
en avait dix comme les calamars ça ça
reste une des très très très très grande
question est ce qu'elle avait une espèce
de tentacules reproductrices aussi
qu'ils servent juste à deux cuillères
pour féconder la femelle
tout ça c'est des questions qu'on se
pose hélas le problème c'est que oui le
grand intérêt d'avoir des tissus mous
d'ammonites ce serait pouvoir répondre à
la question des tentacules et là pour le
coup on n'a pas les tentacules et ne
fait qu'on n'a pas les tentacules
indique un état de décomposition de
destruction du corps très très avancée
qui veut dire que faudrait pas
surinterpréter ce truc là et à mon avis
il ya beaucoup de sur interprétations et
à mon avis est à paris est devenu mais
bref ça ça reste quand même intéressant
on continue sur les noms vertébrés mais
on sort quand même des invertébrés
puisqu'on va s'intéresser aux
champignons une découverte faite de
publier dans nature communications ns
des champignons qui date de l'époque et
dirk aérienne c'est-à-dire d'environ 630
millions d'années qui nous viennent de
chine de l'afo marge de la formation
douche antho formation douchant de tout
mot qui nous avait livré des embryons
possibles notamment des kilos d'herbe et
de plein de trucs dont on pensait qu'il
était apparu qu'après bon après c'est
les interprétations faites sur des
restes microscopiques mais là on a deux
nouveaux reste microscopique qui
ressemble fortement à du mycélium qui
date d'avant le cambrien c'est du
précambrien les diakaria donc c'est
avant la grande explosion de diversité
de la vie est ce qu'il ya d'intéressant
passé que ce mycélium a été retrouvé sur
des dépôts continentaux et pas dans des
dépôts marin ce qui veut dire que ce
mycélium a grandi sur terre c'est le
plus vieil organismes terrestres donc
pas terrestre dans le sens la planète
terre mais bien terrestres dans le sens
sur la terre ferme
donc ça c'est cool ça veut dire qu'il y
avait déjà des organismes vivants à lady
acariens sur la terre ferme
et ça c'est quand même vachement bien et
on termine enfin avec de la géologie
avec cette question qui qui est très qui
est posée très très très très très
souvent par les étudiants comme par les
gens qui suivent la chaîne est-ce qu'on
a retrouvé des morceaux de la météorite
qui a tué les dinosaures
et bien la réponse est oui maintenant
oui
donc voila comme le comme le dit avez
vous déjà vu
maintenant oui en 2021 on peut enfin
dire qu'on a retrouvé des morceaux de la
météorite qui a provoqué le cratère
d'impact de chicxulub dans le golfe du
mexique
il y à 66 millions d'années ils ont fait
des carottages ils ont fait des forages
et il
trouver de la poussière toute petite
poussière
mais cette poussière donc pile à
l'endroit où il ya l'iridium le dire ils
ont retrouvé de la très fine poussière
et ses dépôts de poussières et bien ce
sont des poussières météoritique dont
ils ont fait tout un tas d analyses
géochimiques pour déterminer que c'était
bien de la poussière météoritique j'ai
tendance à les croire même si je ne suis
absolument pas géologue spécialiste donc
je les crois sur parole c'est eux les
experts voyez que là il ya quand même
des pages et des pages de l'analyse je
ne peux pas les détails et je n'ai pas
les compétences pour un dock à voilà si
on vous pose un jour ou si vous vous
posiez la question un jour at on
découvert des morceaux de la météorite
qui a tué les dinosaures
la réponse est maintenant oui on en a
cédé tout petit petit petit poussière au
fond du cratère de chicxulub et alors ce
qui est très marrant c'est que cet
article il a été vendu du genre on sait
en face qui a tué les dinosaures je veux
dire qu'il faut quand même m je veux
éviter d'être vulgaire mais là
franchement il faut quand même être un
sacré jeu ni quintana pour aller dire
pour aller vendre un article en 2021
le dire on est quand même en 2021 et
allait être un journaliste et vendre cet
article en mode on sait en face qui a
tué les dinosaures en 2021 vous rendez
compte que l'impact de crâne enfin
l'impact de chicxulub il a été découvert
à la fin des années 80 le fait qu'une
météorite soit tombé et il ya 66
millions d'années et donc provoquer
l'extinction de la limite crétacé
tertiaire
on le sait depuis le début des années 80
depuis 1981 je crois donc titré en 2021
on sait enfin ce cas tu es les
dinosaures [ __ ] faut être faut avoir
des faut avoir des mauls et déposez-la
quoi ou alors être sacrément ignorant
donc ce qui a réellement intéressant
avec cet article c'est qu'on a on a
enfin une réponse à la question est ce
qu'il y a est-ce qu'on a des restes de
la météorite
maintenant on peut répondre oui avant on
pouvait pas c'est ça qui est intéressant
avec cet article
voilà et si vous avez géologue vous
allez vous éclater avec toutes ces
analyses vous
voilà c'était paléo news je vous
remercie de l'avoir suivi n'oubliez pas
de vous abonner pour ne rien manquer
d'anciens et je vous dis à très bientôt
[Musique]